five four three
two one ignition
[Applause]
[Music]
vehicles
[Applause]
under the power of 5.1 million pounds of
thrust falcon heavy is headed to space
we're throttling down at 2 plus 40
seconds to prepare
for maximum dynamic pressure
power and telemetry are nominal
we're hearing reports power and
telemetry are nominal
vehicles supersonic you may have heard
the call out on
net one vehicle is supersonic
side boosters are throttling back up on
power as we're through the period
of maximum dynamic pressure
trajectory looking good you can hear the
applause behind me as we've gotten past
maximum dynamic pressure
[Applause]
next event coming up is chillin of the
mvacd engine
get the turbo pump ready to ignite the
main
engine on the second stage in another
couple of minutes
merlin engine performance looks good
we've begun dropping power on the side
boosters
to decrease loads on the center core
second load limiting shutdown continuing
to decrease
loads to minimize acceleration on the
falcon heavy structure
coming up on booster engine cut off
called biko and separation of the two
side boosters
right back engine tool
separation from
successful separation if you can hear me
over the cheering
side boosters now beginning a flip
to begin returning back
side boosters have begun the boost back
burn
the center core has throttled back up to
power
everything looking good on the flight of
falcon heavy the next major event
main engine cutoff of the center core
and separation ignition of the second
stage
bottom middle view shows the view
looking up into the nozzle of the second
stage engine
miko main engine cut off center course
again over the cheering mvac d engine up
on power it looks good side boosters
looking good
still burning on their way back to cape
canaveral
grid fans are out on the center corner
here comes the fairing separation and
there it goes
we also have successful shutdown
of the side booster boost back burn
so t-plus four minutes 25 seconds into
flight side boosters on their way back
to cape canaveral
center court coasting out over the
tradition stage two looking good with a
nominal trajectory
and as you guys have noticed the grid
fins have deployed
on the side boosters as well as the
center core those work to help guide the
boosters back to a nice targeted soft
landing
let's see those heading home right now
as a reminder today we'll be attempting
to recover all three of the first stage
cores
and all three boosters are currently on
their way heading home
in just a few minutes the side boosters
will execute an entry burn
followed by a landing burn and the
center core will do much the same a few
minutes later
both burns are meant to slow the stage's
speed down rapidly before landing
at the time of separation the side
boosters were traveling slow enough to
turn around
and make their way back to land at our
side-by-side landing pads
the center core on the other hand is
going too fast to efficiently return
to the cape so we're using our
autonomous drone ship of course i still
love you
if we have a successful landing today
the side boosters will be reflown on our
next falcon heavy mission
stp2
now coming up at about t plus six
minutes will be the side boosters
re-entry burn
acquisition of signal bermuda
so you see the side boosters on your
left and right screen
side booster entry burn has started and
there's the reentry burn beginning
stage two trajectory nominal and the
reentry burn is complete for the side
boosters
now coming up in about 30 seconds the
center core which you see on your center
screen
will begin its reentry burn
stage one energy bearing has started
side boosters are transonic
and there you can see the reentry burn
for center core has begun
coming up in about five seconds here the
side boosters landing burn will begin as
well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what an amazing sight to see
now we're waiting for the engine to shut
down on the second stage
and for the center core to land now if
all goes well
we'll have successfully recovered all
three boosters
which we have never done before
now coming up in about 20 seconds we're
gonna listen for confirmation of ceco
one or second engine cut off one
and we have confirmation
nominal orbit insertion
and we have that confirmed